this group of volunteers is delivering
supplies to Wildfire victims on the
island of Maui although they survived
the Flames they say their future is
uncertain
my heart doesn't ache for my loss and
possessions my heart thanks for my
community you know people that lost
family members friends a lot of people
are still stuck
uh you know on the west side and up
north that without power without food
without water without provisions
and they have no access to that
far destroyed thousands of buildings and
caused an estimated six billion dollars
of damage the government says the
emergency response will be rolled out
over four months
now I want to be honest with everyone
this is also going to be a very long and
hard recovery
but our federal state and local partners
are working around the clock to help all
of those who have been impacted by this
disaster
rescue teams are using cadaver dogs to
help find the dead but there's growing
anger about the early response to the
fire critics say loss of life was
preventable we have Sirens all over the
island they are meant to be for any
emergency no matter what it is and the
fire is an emergency not one siren went
off nobody was warned the sirens as I
had mentioned earlier is used primarily
for tsunamis and that's the reason why
many of them are found almost all of
them are found on the coastline
the public is trained to seek Higher
Ground in the event that the siren is
sounded the highway into Lahaina has
been reopened in a small step on the
road to recovery but elderly people who
lost everything in the fire say they'll
never be able to rebuild their lives
Barbara angopa Al Jazeera
foreign